[Musique]
paris 9 heures du matin
nous sommes devant l'un des magasins
leader des distributeurs de jeux vidéo
en france
prévenir voulait rentrer dans le magasin
grégoire est le responsable du magasin
plusieurs fois par an il invite ses bons
clients à découvrir les produits qui
font fureur
aujourd'hui le jeu qui cartonne nous
vient du japon
il n'a rien d'une course de voiture ou
d'un match de foot en trois dimensions
et prendre la console d'autres fois
c'est un simple jeu sur la mémoire aux
graphismes tout ce qu'il ya de plus
banal calcul mental va commencer 5.4 11
- 8 sa demande de la réactivité et vous
écrivez en fait directement la réponse
sur l'écran tactile autrement dit les
grandes droite des additions des
soustractions des associations de mots
et de couleurs
le jeu est une série d'exercices très
simple qui promet d'abaisser l'âge
théorique de votre cerveau on peut aller
jusqu'à un cerveau de 80 ans
mais le but c'est de se rapprocher d'un
cerveau de 20 ans qui est l'âge a priori
d'un vrai défi intellectuel très
astucieux et qui n'intéresse pas que les
adolescents impossible d'y résister très
longtemps
on entend dire un peu partout que plus
on vieillit plus on perd de neurones et
c'est donc c'est vrai que le fait de le
fait de s'entraîner on y va on ralentit
vieillissement et puis je pense que
c'est intéressant ça fait travailler
toutes les formes de mémoire que soient
la mémoire des chiffres des lettres et
mémoire visuelle la mémoire des couleurs
ça fait effectivement beaucoup
travailler la mémoire le rouge jaune
vous avez quel âge
j'ai 71
raconte c'est très très encourageant
très encourageant surtout par la société
qui commercialise ce jeu il est vendu 30
euros et 30 millions d'exemplaires ont
été vendus dans le monde entier des
centaines de millions de chiffre
d'affaires
depuis ce succès planétaire des dizaines
de nouveaux jeux similaires sont arrivés
sur le marché
le business de la mémoire rapporte gros
aujourd'hui pour des millions de
français
le moindre trouble de la mémoire
inquiète en vieillissant
c'est le spectre d'alzheimer qui menace
et qui fait peur
pour les plus jeunes il s'agit de
réussir un examen scolaire ou améliorer
sa productivité au travail
une véritable course à la performance
certains l'ont bien compris et ils sont
nombreux à vouloir nous vendre des
solutions fabricant de jeux
d'entraînement cérébral de compléments
alimentaires ou encore de coach en
gymnastique du cerveau
le marché de la mémoire est florissant
mais quel crédit accorder à ces nouveaux
produits et ses méthodes d'entraînement
sont ils vraiment efficace et sans
danger
enquête sur le business de la mémoire
[Musique]
nous sommes en gironde à quelques
kilomètres de bordeaux
pascal à 42 ans depuis une dizaine
d'années elle souffre de troubles de la
mémoire
hélas souvent la tête ailleurs en fait
j'ai toujours le doute oublié quelque
chose donc je suis persuadé que j'ai dû
oublier quelque chose c'est certain
comme pour beaucoup de français
alzheimer a touché sa famille son grand
père depuis sa crainte d'être atteintes
par cette maladie ne fait que grandir
j'ai pas fini il reste encore la voiture
tu penseras tous les jours pascal doit
sans cesse compenser les défaillances de
sa mémoire
honnêtement si je ne note pas je suis
sûr d'oublier donc samedi tu m'as 19h30
9h30 alors ok j'ai mon petit agenda et
je suis obligé de monter tous dessus
même si j'ai mon fils à aller chercher à
l'école de peur de l'oublier enfin sens
en carnet c'est pas possible
quand on est âgé on peut se dire dont
c'est normal c'est l'âge mais là à 42
ans oui c'est inquiétant parce qu'elle
est allée consulter son généraliste et
un ostéopathe sans succès aucun
diagnostic n'a pu être établie de quoi
l'inquiéter un peu plus alors
régulièrement elle cherche d'autres
solutions comme celle ci ce fameux jeux
d'entraînement cérébral
j'ai pas mal évolué depuis le début
parce que là franchement j qu'au début
j'étais nul il faut le dire est ce que
ce jeu l'influent sur autour de moi
visiblement non j'ai évolué dans le jeu
certes mais de là à dire que ça
améliorée
les problèmes que j'ai au quotidien en
ce qui concerne ma mémoire et ma
concentration
non en france plus de 2 millions de
personnes utilisent ce jeu comme pascal
pour faire travailler son cerveau un
énorme succès commercial mais est il
utile pour améliorer sa mémoire
[Musique]
direction league online un petit village
en alsace dans la banlieue de strasbourg
[Musique]
dans cette école élémentaire si
tranquille se cache un laboratoire
expérimental offrir à ses vallons on y
va sonia laurent n'est pas institutrice
elle est chercheuse à l'université de
strasbourg
elle travaille sur le cerveau depuis dix
ans pendant six semaines dans le cadre
d'un protocole scientifique ces jeunes
cobayes ont testé le même jeux
d'entraînement cérébral que pascal il
faut bien dessinés avec ton style et
faut vraiment bien faire les chiffres
sinon les chevaux sont à ce repas bio tu
as quel âge
ça sert à nous aider à mémoriser et à
travailler
moi je me sens moi je pense pas que ça
nous a aidés à l'école mais je pense que
c'est pourquoi ça vous n'êtes pas parce
qu'il n'y a pas et il n'y a pas d'indicé
quand même des trucs du cepii le but de
cette étude savoir si ce jeu est
vraiment efficace pour améliorer la
mémoire
l'étude permet de dire scientifiquement
que ça n'a pas un impact ni un effet sur
la mémorisation sur l'attention ni sur
les apprentissages scolaires
maintenant c'est un jeu parmi tant
d'autres jeux on peut jouer à ça jouer à
d'autres types d'activités ça exactement
multi d'impact pourtant la publicité qui
vante ce jeu utilise allègrement un
argumentaire scientifique
un exercice qui active le cortex
préfrontal siège de la créativité et de
la mémoire
alain lieury a dirigé les recherches de
sonia laurent il est responsable du
laboratoire de psychologie expérimentale
de la faculté de rennes
pour lui cette publicité est un mauvais
mélange des genres le cortex préfrontal
n'est pas le siège de la mémoire le
cortex préfrontal est très important
mais tout le cerveau participent à ce
genre d'activités c'est de la publicité
séduction c'est à dire que on est
quelques mots qui sont à la mode comme
le cerveau qui vont avec la vague delà
de la peur de la maladie d'alzheimer
faire croire que si on achète ce
programme là et pas autre chose qu'on va
éviter justement ce genre de troubles
si l'efficacité de ces jeux sont la
mémoire reste à démontrer
cela n'empêche pas les fabricants de
commercialiser sans cesse de nouveaux
produits
[Applaudissements]
villeurbanne près de lyon
c'est dans cette société que sont conçus
les futurs logiciels qui boosteront
notre cerveau fondée il ya dix ans par
trois scientifiques installés en plein
milieu d'un campus universitaire cette
société est devenue leader de son marché
en france plus de 3 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires ces produits se
vendent dans le monde entier europe
amérique du nord japon canada australie
et demain la corée et l'asie
[Musique]
le succès est tel qu'ils l'ont même
adapter leurs logiciels sur un nouveau
support
les téléphones mobiles un marché très
prometteur donc l'intérêt c'est
justement aussi de deviner quel tiroir
cache quelques catégories de mots il
s'en souvenir le but avant tout c'est
que ce soit un jeu ludique c'est
vraiment destiné à des personnes qui ont
envie de jouer en même temps améliorer
leurs capacités cognitives telles que la
mémoire l'attention faire travailler sa
mémoire mais pas seulement
tout est minutieusement pensé pour que
le client ne lâche pas son téléphone
portable
il faut qu'on réfléchisse à ce qu'on va
mettre dans la version gratuite est ce
qu'on mettra dans la version payante
puisque la pratique c'est que les gens
ils téléchargent gratuitement un jeu il
regarde ça leur plaît du coup ils vont
voir pour acheter la version payante
qu'elle donne bien l'image de ce qu'il
ya à l'intérieur mais qu'elle te frustre
suffisait pas là sinon si tu te
contentes gratuite
et ça marche sur tous les supports
internet livres cd rom l'offre grand
public est large et se porte bien en
allemagne certains logiciels se vendent
par centaines de milliers d'exemplaires
philippe mestral un des responsables
commerciaux ne se cache pas de surfer
sur la peur d'alzheimer il ya vraiment
une prise de conscience à la fois du
problème d'alzheimer et la fois de
l'existence de moyens pour la même
manière qu'on va faire son jogging dans
le parc
de façon jogging cérébrale de chez soi
avec une console avec un internet avec
un pc avec deux mains son téléphone
portable
c'est un marché qui est là pour
longtemps et va même continuer à croître
au fil au fil du temps au fur et à
mesure que de nouvelles personnes se
laisse convaincre par les bienfaits
l'entraînement cérébral un marché qui a
donc de beaux jours devant lui
mais les logiciels de cette société sont
ils vraiment efficaces pour entraîner
notre mémoire
nous avons demandé alain lieury un autre
chercheur de tester un cd rom de cette
société lyonnaise coach cérébral
l'objectif de ce programme
d'entraînement faire travailler tous les
types de mémoire associer des noms de
capital à des pays pour booster la
mémoire culturelle away retenir des
formes et des couleurs pour améliorer la
mémoire récente
une série de jeux très basique qui
laisse les chercheurs un petit peu
sceptique ça fait pas partie d'un
programme d'entraînement cérébral
spécifique à plein de jeux comme ça je
me souviens qu'on était tout petit on
avait une carte avec des plots
électrique et puis on devait mettre rome
en italie éléphants en afrique et puis
ça il ya une lumière qui s'allumaient
ces jeux sont juste des recettes qui
prétendent améliorer l'apprentissage
mais qui en fait qu'ils ne sont basées
sur aucune étude scientifique tout ça
c'est complètement du business on essaye
de faire de l'argent avec deux avec des
exercices qui existait déjà il ya 50 ou
60 ans mais qu'on habille avec les
nouveaux environnements numériques
ça sert à rien d'acheter ce jeu plutôt
que de voir n'importe quel documentaire
que de faire un voyage que de faire un
voyage graslin journaux que d'aller au
cinéma que de regarder la télévision
donc on ne peut pas dire que ce jeu en
lui-même est inutile il doit simplement
s'inscrire dans d'autres activités
conscient des limites de ses logiciels
d'entraînement cérébral
certains clients se tournent vers
d'autres solutions plus personnalisés
notre enquête se poursuit à paris à la
découverte des centres de coaching
cérébrale
nous sommes place de la concorde dans un
des quartiers les plus chers de la
capitale depuis 14 ans monique le poncin
docteur en biologie organise des stages
de gym cerveau prend deux jours et pour
la somme de 290 euros les stagiaires
sont censés retrouver un capital de 100
% de mémorisation
parmi cette clientèle quelque peu
élitiste
la nouvelle tendance ce sont les jeunes
lycéens collégiens et même des élèves de
primaire
plus de méthodologie pour apprendre mes
cours histoire de gagner du temps et
puis de mieux organiser mes
connaissances je suis un chercheur du
cerveau donc ce que je vais vous amener
c'est une méthode qui est vraiment basée
sur le fonctionnement du cerveau c'est
pour ça que j'appelle ça toujours du
neuro manage mat pour tout le monde crie
des mots pourquoi pas vous je vais vous
dire effectivement que vous avez tous
une mémoire d'éléphant
mais vous savez pas utilisé allez-y vous
mettez comme ça vous revient attention
la méthode de monique le poncin et bien
huilé plus de 20 ans pour la mettre au
point
il faut mémoriser le maximum de farm
le programme se veut très complet cours
sur le cerveau de mémorisation de forme
de lettres de chiffres
en quelques heures une batterie
d'exercices se succèdent donc je vais
dire une liste 15 vous que vous écoutez
que vous essayez de mémoriser on est
dans la performance de ma mère violon
arbres
le test ultime mémoriser une liste de 15
mo le fer de lance de la méthode de
monique le poncin outils chasseurs sow
campagne en quelques minutes elle va
répéter la liste cinq fois entre chaque
lecture
les stagiaires doivent essayer de
retrouver les 15 mo sans se tromper
violon jean schalit et xian à chassieu
sort en panne au bout de la cinquième
fois le résultat est sans surprise
est ce que quelqu'un a trouvé les cases
au 5e essai non normalement cet après
midi en deux et ses opus en trois essais
quel que soit l'âge on doit et va avoir
les casinos sur 15 la promesse est clair
une mémorisation maximum en seulement
quelques heures d'exercice grâce à une
astuce toute simple tant qu'on va mettre
le violent d'éclat la cravate avec le
genre ont la belle vie avec l'accusé à
l'oreille avec le couteau et sky même si
ces mots n'ont rien à voir entre eux
il faut les mémoriser dans l'ordre en
les associant par couple deux par deux
ce qui veut dire que là nous sommes plus
qu'à sept pour le cerveau et non plus la
case et c'est parti pour une liste de
quinze nouveaux mots orange fauteuil
crapaud bouchons
la méthode de mémorisation a l'air
simple mais est elle efficace la plus
nulle de la classe tout de suite là
c'est magique mais en général ça demande
aux gens à peu près six mois pour
véritablement le négocier d'une façon
complètement automatisés
la méthode de monique le poncin semble
fonctionner mais cette technique de
mémorisation est elle réellement
novatrice c'est ce qu'on fait à l'école
depuis la renaissance
donc ça c'est efficace mais ce sont des
exercices scolaires défendu comme
méthode tout à fait classique
c'est bien d'ailleurs qu'il en soit
ainsi mais ces deux là c'est du
charlatanisme que de vendre tel métal
même si les avis sont partagés sur ce
type de méthode
chaque année monique le poncin reçoit
plusieurs centaines de stagiaires dans
son centre de coaching cérébrale mais
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de français
choisissent une autre solution pour
améliorer leur mémoire
les pilules
en france plus de 70000 pharmacie se
partagent un nouveau marché très
lucratif
les compléments alimentaires
plus d'un milliard d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires chaque année selon ufc que
choisir
une aubaine pour les pharmacies à
l'intérieur des linéaires à perte de vue
souvent à quelques mètres à peine des
médicaments vendus sur ordonnance
médicale
et pour traiter les pertes de la mémoire
le complément alimentaire qui fait
fureur c'est le ginkgo biloba surnommé
l'arbre de jouvence une plante venue du
japon qui améliore le transport sanguin
dans le cerveau pour s'en procurer nous
sommes rentrés dans une pharmacie
parisienne
prétextant un cas de légers troubles de
la mémoire
nous demandons un traitement efficace à
base de compléments alimentaires
une avalanche de termes scientifiques
très compliqué le discours de la
pharmacienne se veut rassurant
évidemment elle nous propose aussitôt le
ginkgo biloba ok donc qu'est-ce qu'il ya
les autres
jean cau d'accord et les jeunes qu il
est là pour agir sur le système
le réseau veineux en fait efficace en
plus du djing octobre à cette
pharmacienne va nous vendre un autre
complément alimentaire à base d'oméga 3
un acide gras essentiel pour le
fonctionnement du cerveau que l'on
trouve principalement dans le poisson
au total trois mois de traitement
in addition très salée alors par contre
c'est un sacré budget commun 218 euros
pour des produits qui contrairement à la
plupart des médicaments ne sont pas
remboursés
mais sont ils réellement efficace et que
trouve-t-on dans ces compléments
alimentaires nous avons fait analyser
l'un d'entre eux dans un laboratoire
les résultats sont surprenants du
concentré d'ananas de pamplemousse des
minéraux des vitamines
le ginkgo biloba lui est présent en très
petite quantité des pourcentages proche
de zéro que penser alors de l'efficacité
réelle de ces compléments alimentaires
[Musique]
nous avons contacté un des responsables
du laboratoire qui fabrique ce produit
je m'interroge sur ses valeurs de
pourcentage de ginkgo biloba ils sont
quand même relativement faible alors on
travaille avec des pour des pourcentages
de plantain et sur le
sur la vie de la biblio les modes en
afrique et l'ont fait sur la plante
ginkgo biloba mais vous vous en avez les
insulter
jeu 7 responsables restent floues et
pour cause
aujourd'hui aucune étude clinique ne
démontre le lien entre le ginkgo biloba
et l'amélioration de la mémoire
pourtant sur la boîte la publicité est
prometteuse où la réglementation au
tourisme aux allégations aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous avez une grande parce
que ça soit opaque et aujourd'hui on se
fout attendre et aujourd'hui en tout cas
réels m'a dit que je n'ai pas le droit
mc oui mais est-ce qu'on peut venir
faire un interview filmée chez vous
boirez tout ça voilà j'ai crespin
pourquoi le fait qu'au bout le paraguay
ont été souvent les responsables du
laboratoire n'en dirons pas plus
direction la faculté de médecine de
bobigny en région parisienne le
professeur hercberg est un grand
spécialiste de la nutrition et des
compléments alimentaires depuis 20 ans
nous lui avons soumis nos résultats d'
analyse qu à la lecture de ces résultats
ce que l'on voit c'est que ce produit ne
contient quasiment aucun extrait de
ginkgo biloba à des quantités qui peut
permettre d'espérer la moindre
efficacité
on est proche de la poudre de
perlimpinpin il ya aucun travail
scientifique qui justifie de penser que
ce produit à la moindre efficacité donc
il n'y a aucune chance que ce qui
entraîne la moindre amélioration de
votre mémoire de vos fonctions
intellectuelles ou de votre santé
pourtant c'est marqué sur la boîte
alors c'est le décalage qu'il ya entre
des produits qui contiennent rien
d'efficace et puis du marketing et de la
publicité surtout du business c'est de
la fausse promesse qui est pas tout à
fait honnête parce que là on joue sur
les fantasmes et les peurs qui n'a pas
peur de perdre la mémoire et qui soit ne
souhaiterait pas amélioré son activité
intellectuelle et tout ceci ne repose
sur aucune base scientifique réelle pour
le professeur hercberg
la faible qualité de ce produit n'est
pas une exception
tous ces compliments n'ont strictement
aucun intérêt vend du rêve jouent sur
les fantasmes mais c'est du pur
marketing de la publicité
il vaut mieux suivre des recommandations
nutritionnelles manger du poisson
régulièrement du poisson gras manger des
fruits et légumes des produits complets
à voir l'activité physique pour
améliorer sa mémoire et la qualité de sa
santé
malgré tout le marché du complément
alimentaire est en pleine forme il
devrait progresser de 10%
les deux prochaines années
pascal elle aussi à essayer des
compléments alimentaires sans succès
elle souffre toujours de troubles de la
mémoire et redoutent d'être atteinte par
la maladie d'alzheimer aujourd'hui elle
a rendez vous dans cet hôpital parisien
pour connaître la vérité au plus
j'avance on va dire mais je stresse mais
bon c'est c'est moi qui ait fait ce
choix de de faire ces tests et d'en
savoir un peu plus sur cette maladie
d'alzheimer à savoir si je suis atteinte
ou non
donc voilà qui a plus qu'à attendre le
docteur lisette volpé gillot est à la
fois neurologue et gériatre c'est elle
qui est responsable des consultations
mémoire de l'hôpital saint joseph
pascal appréhende le verdict des
médecins pour l'aider à vivre cette
difficile épreuve
elle a demandé à sa belle-mère d'être à
ses côtés
[Musique]
première étape un bilan médical très
complet
avec un fait
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de comprendre
un petit peu pourquoi vous avez les
difficultés dont je vous avais parlé
vous allez me dire quel jour on est
aujourd'hui on est le 11
oui alors quel jour de la semaine
vendredi
ensuite le mms le mini mental score un
examen assez simple qui va juger l'état
mental de pascal d'accord comment ça
s'appelle pour s'assurer un crayon enfin
dernière chose pour ce test vous allez
prendre cette feuille dans la main
droite
la plier en deux et l'a jeté par terre
lié on veut jeter par terre c'est pas
faire ça va ça vous met en confiance ça
comme un lieu jusque là oui non
des tests qui viennent d'être utilisés
sont des tests qui sont utilisés dans la
majorité des consultations mémoire etc
des thèses qui sont utilisés pour avoir
une première approche qui peuvent
parfois déjà donné une bonne idée mais
dans le cas de madame rihanna seront pas
suffisants pour vraiment avoir une idée
et pour savoir si elles souffrent
vraiment d'alzheimer il faut changer de
pièce et suivent cet homme un
neuropsychologue je vous montre un
chemin dans un sens et après mot fait
dans le sens inverse
ces tests psychométriques vont durer
deux heures degré de concentration
rapidité de compréhension face à un
problème tout est analysé
je vais vous demander de faire des
gestes vous allez tout d'abord faire les
mêmes gestes que moi
[Musique]
avec les deux mains est ce que pouvait
faire le geste des marionnettes
oui pouvez-vous applaudir en quoi une
orange une banane se ressemblent ce sont
tous les deux des fruits encore la
cuillère la fourchette se ressent
[Musique]
sondés
georges comment
et couverts ça vous a paru difficile
fatiguant difficile sur certaines choses
oui et on est fatiguée un petit peu
quand même quelques minutes sont
nécessaires à l'équipe du docteur volpé
gillot pour analyser les résultats
[Musique]
oui après
pascal va enfin trouver des réponses à
ses questions vos performances peuvent
pas être considérée comme normale c'est
à dire que vous n'avez pas un profil de
type maladie d'alzheimer très bien donc
voilà vous y pensiez réellement ah oui
oui oui oui oui c'est à dire que bon mon
grand père paternel est décédé de ça
donc c'est vrai que ça fait peur ouais
ça fait peur mais vous y pensiez pour
vous même
ah oui j'y pense et ça c'est sûr pour
autant ce que vous étiez très bien c'est
que vous au quotidien vous avez des
difficultés c'est pas dramatique
notre anxiété peut être en grande partie
voire totalement oui responsable de ça
parce qu'elle était persuadée d'avoir la
maladie d'alzheimer mais comme beaucoup
de personnes du même âge son cas n'a
rien d'alarmant seulement un peu de
stress dans sa vie professionnelle et
beaucoup de manques de concentration
est ce qu'il y a éventuellement quelque
chose à faire pour ma part à la maison
ou quoi que ce soit d'aider des petits
tests des petits jeux je sais pas en
fait
alors vous êtes en activité
professionnelle on peut estimer que
c'est déjà une stimulation qui est
importante comme conseil j'allais dire
de bon sens c'est ne pas s'enfermer
sécher soit continuer à voir du monde
sortir donc je veux dire avoir une vie
aussi sociale épanouie et y prendre
plaisir s'il ya des choses qui vous font
plaisir si ça vous fait plaisir de faire
des mots croisés allez-y mais ne le fait
pas en vous disant c'est une
thérapeutique
c'est il faut à la fois plaisir voilà
[Musique]
en 2008 comme pascal près d'un millier
de personnes ont poussé les portes de
cet hôpital pour suivre une consultation
mémoire
parmi eux 60 % étaient atteints par la
maladie d'alzheimer un chiffre qui
augmente sans cesse avec 165 mille
nouveaux cas chaque année en france
cette maladie n'a donc pas fini de faire
peur
le business de la mémoire a encore de
très beaux jours devant lui
[Musique]